in this problem a dissolved oxygen probe
tracking an industrial discharge goes
offline during a given period during
this time the flow rate of the discharge
was held steady at 5 MGD a USGS gauge in
the river Upstream of the discharge
measured the river's flow to be 30 CFS
while at a temperature of 30° C another
temperature probe Downstream of the
discharge recorded the river's
temperature to be 34° C assume the
atmospheric pressure is 760 mm of
mercury and that this is a freshwater
river and that the discharge has no
salinity if the river is fully saturated
with dissolved oxygen both upstream and
downstream of the discharge there is no
oxygen
deficit what is the dissolved oxygen in
milligrams per liter of the
discharge so this problem is a pretty
straightforward mass balance problem the
most important thing we need is the
reference manual table for dissolved
oxygen concentrations in water as a
function of temperature and
salinity the 24th occurrence of the word
oxygen would get you to this table in
the manual if you're totally clueless
about where to begin and you're just
looking through all occurrences of the
word but it will probably be more
helpful if you can at least remember
that this table exists so that you can
speed up your search for this reference
so aside from this minor curve ball all
we need to do now is standardize our
units and complete the mass balance as
we would any other mass
balance so step one we can convert 5 MGD
to CFS using a conversion rule if you
don't remember this rule you can also
Solve IT long hand and cancel out all of
the units the reference manual also
contains the inverse of this conversion
CFS to MGD on page three
now for step two we can find the
temperatures given in the problem on the
reference table and look up their
corresponding do
concentrations the problem notes that we
have no solinity so we can use the
values from the First Column where
salinity equals
zero so the river's flow Upstream of the
discharge is 30°
C the table tells us that the dissolved
oxygen concentration at this temperature
is about
7.54 mg per l
Additionally the problem tells us that
the probe Downstream of the discharge
records the river's temperature to be
34°
[Music]
C the corresponding do concentration for
this temperature is
7.05 mg per liter so now that we have
our Doo concentrations we can set up and
solve the mass
balance so our discharge flow rate is
going to be given as
7.74 cubic feet per
second and our temperature and our Doo
concentration is unknown
[Music]
here the
river flow was given as 30
CFS Upstream of the
[Music]
discharge and the 30°
gave us a do
concentration of
7.54 mg per
liter finally the problem didn't give us
the flow but we need to
know that the combined values from the
discharge and the river are going to
be the combined flow
here so 37.7
combination of 30 and
7.74 cubic feet per second
times our corresponding Doo for our 34°
here is
7.05 milligrams per
liter just to clarify that goes
there and this is for here
[Music]
and simplifying down this mass balance
we can find that X is going to equal
5.15 millgram per liter which is very
close to our first answer
here so I should note that in this
problem if you solve in terms of
temperature first you're going to find
that the temperature of the industrial
discharge is higher than the upper limit
of what the table covers about
50° this is an answer on the test as you
can see here which you might pick if you
aren't paying close attention to your
units that's why we used the table for
our known temperatures instead 30 and 34
degrees and then solved for D directly
after that using their corresponding
values in the mass balance equation
instead if this happens to you on the
test and you accidentally solve in terms
of temperature first don't worry just
solve the mass balance problem again
after using the do table
first and that's it